bonsoir à tous ravis de vous retrouver
ça vous regarde version des conflits nés
c'est parti voici le sommaire le
qu'ovide va-t-il tuer le foot français
depuis deux mois tout est arrêté les
matches comme les championnats européens
sans compter que les chaînes ont coupé
le robinet des droits télé alors quelles
pistes pour sauver l'économie du foot
français au bord du gouffre la
distanciation sociale est elle
compatible avec les joies du stade on en
parle dans un instant avec nos invités à
l'heure où certains élus n'hésitent pas
à dénoncer la décision brutale du
gouvernement qu'on les appelle déjà les
nouveaux pauvres du coronavirus c'est
l'une des premières conséquences de la
récession économique l'envolée des
demandes aide alimentaire jusqu'à + 30 %
dans certaines régions de france des
appels aux dons sont lancés des chèques
d'urgence débloquée suffisant ou pas
pour contenir la crise sociale qui se
profile notre grand débat à suivre et
puis et puis comme chaque soir le jour
d'après nouvel épisode de notre
collection d'entretien thématique ce
soit le sexe à la veille de ce grand
week-end de l'ascension qu'est ce que
cette période si étrange a changé dans
notre rapport au corps ou couple et
notre vie sexuelle
la réalisatrice ovidie a répondu à nos
questions
voilà donc pour le programme ces partis
hashtag sévère ça ça n'a pas changé
[Musique]
et bienvenue à vous chers
téléspectateurs merci d'avoir choisi lcp
même les parlementaires ne comprennent
pas les décisions du gouvernement sur le
foot français depuis que le premier
ministre leur annoncer ça la saison
2019-2020 de sport professionnel
notamment celle de football ne pourra
pas non plus reprendre alors depuis
d'hier ils sont plusieurs élus notamment
au sénat a interpellé la ministre des
sports mais pourquoi diable cette
décision aussi radicale le choix de
mettre un terme à la saison de ligue 1
est il judicieux alors alors que nos
voisins allemands redémarre bonsoir
sacha ollier bonsoir et merci d'être en
direct sur ce plateau vous êtes député
la république en marge de la vienne
fan inconditionnel de l'olympique de
marseille est l'auteur d'un rapport avec
l'ancien ministre des sports marie
george buffet publié aujourd'hui sur le
monde des supporters
on en dira un mot au cours de notre
discussion face à vous karim nedjari
bonsoir bonsoir et bienvenue sur lcp
vous êtes directeur éditorial sport du
groupe webedia un journaliste et
consultant à la chaîne l'équipe on a
parlé donc de cette manière dont le
gouvernement gère à cette crise
sanitaire dans le foot français mais
d'abord le regard de blacko sur ce qui
se trame dans le foot alors du co lead
sait si j'ai bien compris le voilà blaco
dans sa bibliothèque c'est parti
bonsoir stéphane si j'ai bien compris
derrière bonsoir à tous mais si j'ai
bien compris merial on se demande bien
pourquoi le gouvernement a décidé
d'annuler les championnats de france de
football
c'est tellement incompréhensible avait
dit que ya même deux sénateurs qui ont
écrit un courrier à liszt demander des
explications
et c'est vrai qu'on a du mal à
comprendre en espagne en italie et en
angleterre les joueurs ont repris
l'entraînement en allemagne nous l'avait
dit il ya eu des matchs pour démarrer à
huis clos et pendant ce temps là au pays
des champions du monde en france le
football reste interdite alors comment
expliquer ça et là le problème c'est
qu'en france on a un grand respect pour
les intellectuels mais on a tendance à
mépriser un petit peu les sportifs
la preuve on va dire jusqu'où ça va même
la ministre des sports estime que le
sport n'a aucune importance que c'est un
truc totalement secondaire
je montre un article de l'équipe où cet
extrait mis fin à l'élan dix ans le
sport ne sera pas prioritaire dans notre
société
elle n'en revient pas c'est quand même
curieux ce mépris du sport pour nice des
sceaux enfin bon je comprends je
comprends avec le virus
la priorité des priorité désormais c'est
la santé des français bah oui mais
justement le sport c'est bon pour la
santé
non mais ça il faut le savoir il ya une
étude américaine qui a été publié dans
le parisien au début janvier regarder 30
minutes d'activité par jour 20 font sens
de risque de cancer en moins alors que
peut-être que le gouvernement devra peut
être revoir l'ordre de ses priorités
prenons un exemple l'opéra de paris
prague là il touche 95 millions d'euros
de subventions chaque année la
fédération française de football elle
touche 4 millions et demi alors là c'est
une question de priorité qu'est ce qui
est prioritaire
est-ce que c'est l'expérience
bookingdooh paris qui brille et qui
pétillent ou est ce que c'est une
activité sportive avec plus de deux
millions de licenciés
quatre cent mille bénévoles chacun aura
sa réponse sur cette question j'imagine
bien mais pourquoi vous inciter à ne pas
être trop sévère avec le football je
voudrais laisser la parole à un prix
nobel de littérature
il nous donne son avis sur le football
albert camus le peu de morale que je
jallet a pris sur les scènes de théâtre
et dans les stades de football qui
resteront mes vraies universités alors
voyez ses parents qu'il dit on apprend
plus de choses sur un terrain de foot
que sur les bancs d'école bon vu que
l'école a repris doit être ok merci
stéphane vous restez avec nous karim
nedjari avant de nous dire c'est
gouvernement a pris les bonnes décisions
dans le foot face au co vide j'aimerais
qu'on essaye de faire un état des lieux
sur cette crise que traverse le foot
français
le virus il est venu frapper un secteur
qui était déjà en crise le football
français trimballe depuis des années un
déficit énorme structurelles
aujourd'hui il ya des vrais problèmes il
a une espèce de dépendance des droits
télé donc cette crise là est venue
frapper de manière conjoncturelle déjà
un secteur qui était en danger
structurellement donc quand on a arrêté
un petit peu brutalement le football
français et des chaînes de télévision
ont décidé de couper le robinet d'argent
donc c'est à peu près 250 millions
d'euros que canal+ et vince portes n'ont
pas donné si on y ajoute aujourd'hui
tout ce qui est sponsor
si on y ajoute les droits d'entrée si on
y ajoute les loges vip et tout ça c'est
sans doute un budget de 600 millions
d'euros
donc le football français qui était au
bord du gouffre est tombé oui mais il
faut bien dire une chose le gouvernement
a pris une décision en mettant la santé
en premier
donc ça c'est juste et tout le monde
peut le comprendre en france le football
français est dans cette situation là à
cause de ses dirigeants ses propres
dirigeants qui n'arrivent pas à
s'entendre entre eux la preuve en est
c'est que là le gouvernement fait un
geste exceptionnel en leur donnant 250
millions d'euros on va y venir en aide
oui là ils vont toucher encore de
quasiment 1 milliards des nouveaux
droits d'un groupe sino espagnol qui va
arriver mais n'arrive pas à se partager
entre eux et se divise tout le temps est
donc cette division et cette situation
ils ne le doivent
comme pour bien comprendre qu'est ce qui
fait le plus de dégâts
c'est l'arrêt
des droits des chaînes où le fait qu'il
n'y ait plus de supporters qui viennent
qui viennent au stade
acheter des tickets non là dans l'est
dans les budgets
aujourd'hui 60% 70% c'est les droits
télé ensuite la balle à billetterie et
tout ça vient juste après donc le
problème il ya un problème économique
mais qui est doublé d'un problème
populaire on en parlera après évidemment
que c'est terrible parce que le football
qui s'arrête ce qui ne les économies le
football est tout à fait la zone combien
de personnes dont quelque 40000
personnes aujourd'hui qui dépendent du
football sans compter de tout ce qui est
bénévolat tout ce qui compte l'éducateur
de banlieue et tous attendent là tout à
l'heure blaco expliqué donc ça c'est un
vrai un vrai problème
et en plus c'est doublée d'une amende de
caumont diaz ça fait du ce lien social
le football dont ne pas lancer le
football ça casse aussi une dynamique on
en parlera tout à l'heure avec les
supporters les supporters aujourd'hui il
ya la vie de la journée et le week-end
si vous leur prix supprimer ce qui passe
le week-end il ya moins de saveur dans
la dans la semaine ça c'est un vrai
c'est un vrai c'est un vrai souci
donc je pense qu'on a on s'est un peu
précipité on aurait pu voir jusqu'au
donné rendez-vous comme l'ont fait les
allemands dans les allemands déjà repris
mais comme l'ont fait les italiens comme
on fait les espagnols ont été beaucoup
plus touchés par qu'on a viré chez nous
donc on s'est un peu précipité
parce que je pense qu'il ya eu un délit
de sale gueule du football parce que le
football c'est le football business et
donc le symbole de la lettre en oublier
le football populaire dont vous parlez
dans votre rapport dans votre rapport
vous voyez les choses de la même manière
à peu près moi je pense qu'il ya trois
questions qui se posent au regard de ce
qui est l'arrêt de la saison et des
saisons d'abord il ya la question du
football amateur que je distingue du
football professionnel et football
amateur
là où ça pose un énorme problème l'arrêt
des saisons c'est sur la question des
revenus du football amateur c'est pour
ça que j'ai écrit à noël le graet que
marie george buffet l'a fait également
pour des questions de fond de soutien au
football amateur mais en général aux
sports amateurs parce que les lotos les
tombolas les tournois de jeunes qui est
organisée pour finalement financer les
clubs
eh bien il ya un véritable gouffre
financier qui se creusent et sur
laquelle la fédération qui était un
délégataire de service public
est ce que dans le code du sport l'etac
confère le service public du sport aux
fédérations sportives et bien à une
responsabilité qui est majeure le
deuxième point celui du football
professionnel qui lui
subdivise le côté économique dont on a
parlé on est effectivement on arrête
avec des problèmes de répartition et
avec des dirigeants qui sont pas à la
hauteur aujourd'hui parce que alors même
si la ligue a fait de gros progrès ces
dernières années et s'est
institutionnalisée pour faire notamment
des progrès dans le domaine des
supporteurs mais avec des dirigeants
aujourd'hui qu'ils n'arrivent pas à
s'entendre pour faire se chamailler
plutôt que s'organiser pour d'abord
répartir le gaz issus de trouver de
nouvelles recrues dans le fonctionnement
fonctionnement même du jeu c'est le
deuxième point est le troisième point il
a trés finalement à l'entourage parce
qu'une fois qu'on a parlé économie dans
le sport professionnel
on a aussi le côté passionnel du sport
professionnel et le côté passionnel
c'est tout le côté supporters et ce qui
pourrait motiver ce qui explique assez
justement la décision du gouvernement
sur la red du sport professionnel c'est
parce que un stade qui est vide un stade
qui est à huis clos
c'est pas un stade de football c'est
quelque chose dont kelly manque principe
une chose qui est majeure c'est son âme
et pour le coup ne pas admettre des
supporters dans un stade de football
et bien c'est priver toute une partie du
sel de la compétition alors on va
continuer la discussion mais c'était fin
même à distance et c'est ça aussi la
télé ou à dire version des copines et
veut réagir
stéphane blakowski ouais je j'en étais
l'argumentation sa cheville est sûr
c'est pas possible parce que l'âme n'est
pas dans le stade
moi je suis ça moyen comme argument
politique a demandé aux sites web et moi
je pense que les supporters il serait
ravi de voir des matches à huis clos il
ya pas de souscrire moi j'ai six heures
du conflit avec le football
vous dites le vous le savent pas gérer
leur argent tout vient de la télé mais
on ça serait pareil pour le cinéma s'ils
ont pris le cinéma de droits télé cinéma
s'arrête c'est voilà c'est un spectacle
c'est normal c'est un argument
économique pour 201 déprécier le
footballeur 10 ans escaliers d'ailleurs
martin aouladi en allemagne où sont
repris pour des raisons économiques
manière de dire qu'ils ont pris pour de
mauvaises raisons j'ai ils ont repris
pour déposer le bilan ne pas déposer de
bilan c'est une très bonne vague alors
justement sur la crise économique et
aujourd'hui vous diriez que les pouvoirs
publics ont pris la mesure du risque
économique pour certains clubs qui
pourrait déposer le bilan
oui mais en fait moi ce que je
je comprends pas c'est à quel point le
gouvernement ne se rend pas compte de ce
qui se passe en ce moment c'est à dire
que aujourd'hui il ya des rapaces des
fonds de pension qui viennent dans le
foot français
simplement pour faire du business voilà
c'est des fonds de pension qui viennent
à lille
exemple à lille à bordeaux où une
situation incroyable où le maire
visiblement bon enfin s'y intéresser en
fait pourquoi ils viennent parce que il
voit arriver le milliard 200 millions
qui va arriver plus tard mais cet argent
là souvent il a été non ti avant pour
payer des transferts juste un chiffre
que les gens doivent retenir les
transferts c'est quand un joueur passe
d'un club à un autre ça c'est à cet
argent-là part en fumée
rien que par les intermédiaires et les
agents qui se met dans la poche dont on
peut dire qu'il est dépensée avant les
dépenses vers mahut
oui avant même maintenant pour répondre
à deux choses en anglais et en allemagne
il pouvait sans doute recommencer parce
que le poids des droits du foot des
droits de la télévision est moins fort
qu'en france il ya une dépendance dont
un au monde voilà est juste stéphane qui
est un vrai passé les fautes savoir une
chose c'est que les 42 associations
d'ultras en france s'étaient proposés
contre la reprise de football harry de
choses dans ce qui est dit effectivement
l'argument de l'allemagne ce n'est pas
un argument économique parce que pour le
coup le football allemand est beaucoup
plus équilibré en son sein de ce
qu'avait génèrent des ressources et
parce qu'ils ont sécurisé une chose qui
est la propriété des clubs la propriété
des clubs allemands est à majorité
allemandes c'est une règle qui est qui
est applicable en allemagne et qui fait
que par exemple si on prend leur assène
ball les digues qui s'appelle le r&b
l'exil il n'a pas pu être achetée par
une grande marque de soda parce que
précisément là cette marque là était
autrichienne et a pouvait pas rentrer au
capital de façon majoritaire etc des
règles qu'on n'a pas en france qui
pourraient être prises d'ailleurs par
parler vite pour protéger des
investisseurs étrangers qui auraient pu
être prises avant des investissements
dans des grands clubs y compris
olympique de marseille ou y compris le
paris saint germain mais sur ces
questions on a fait ça c'est sur
l'organisation même du football allemand
par rapport au nôtre mais est ce que ça
peut expliquer qu'il reprenne avant nous
bah non non c'est ce qui est ce qui
explique qu'ils reprennent avant nous
c'est que pour le coup il n'y a pas eu
de décision globale d'arrêt des
championnats et que pour le coup les
fédérations les leaks sont totalement
derrière ont convié le show sur la
reprise
pourquoi les allemands repli avant nous
c'est que visiblement il était mieux
préparé aussi à ce qui s'est passé en
france
lutter contre le coc vide c'est-à-dire
qu'ils avaient beaucoup plus de pistolet
pour la température de masques et tout
ça ils ont depuis l'autre chose c'est
que les footballeurs français par leurs
syndicats se sont déclarés contre la
reprise aussi par la voix de cieux ce
cast ndoh donc le président de la
république lorsque te disent les joueurs
ne veulent pas reprendre certains
présidents voyant leurs propres intérêts
parce que c'était leur intérêt que le
championnat s'arrête pour pouvoir être
dans les trois premiers et donc toucher
les droits de la ligue des champions
donc que c'était de dire on gèle à 28 il
ya un effet complètement pervers en fait
il ya que deux présidents qui avait
vraiment une opposition très franches à
l'arrêt c'était le président daniel
président de lyon pour être assez précis
alors pas de lumière pas damien parce
que là lui si ça s'arrêtait une amie
l'ex dame et young qui était opposé à
c'était assez assez tard et a testé huit
y avait le président de brest aussi mais
tout ça en vrai en vraie opposition
ferme aujourd'hui qui combattent la
décision qui a été prise par les
pouvoirs publics ou pas ou par les
ligues cc deux présidents qui mène le
combat alors il ya des freins en interne
au sein du foot français très clairement
je vous ai compris qu et puis stéphane
qu'un vrai passionné et un expert de
faut qu'on se faisait contrer que les
tirs
voilà je ne suis pas professionnel je
les nie joueurs s'organisent sur
l'allemagne c'est un mouvement général
sawar repos en espagne ça va reprendre
en italie ça va reprendre en angleterre
les joueurs sont à l'entraînement ça
reprend dans pour me focalise focalise
sur l'allemagne c'est un mouvement
général en europe il ya une anomalie
française simplement interdire le
football mais il faut qu est un sport
interdit même si le gouvernement s'est
précipité le foot c'est intéressant
c'est que le football français c'est
tiré lui même une balle mais dans les
deux pieds dans les deux pieds c'était
l'été au bord du gouffre il sait pousser
mais encore aujourd'hui on arrive même
alors on vient de rentrer dans ce studio
là on vient de se rendre compte que la
ligue 2 finalement va passer à 22
oui pourquoi parce que pourquoi parce
qu'en énergie à 22 équipes la saison
pour les chaînes pour ça veut dire qu'on
veut sauver pour sauver certains
certains clubs économiquement parce que
quand vous descendez de la ligue 1 la
ligue 2 ce n'est plus le même droit
donc on se dit on va geler mais si on
fait ça dans ses carnets faut faire la
même chose en ligue 1 mais qu'est ce
qu'il attend le politique pour aller
mettre son nez là dedans et dehors il
faut repartir on est en train de
vraiment de comprendre là on joue contre
l'intérêt de la france et de son
football
d'abord l'annoncé du premier ministre
elle concerne toutes les ligues
professionnelles et tous les
championnats
donc elle concerne pas uniquement le
football que la tpr y voilà elle a été
prise cette décision au moment du des
confirmands le 28 avril avec les
éléments dont disposaient elle a été
prise alors que l'opinion publique
française est autrement plus exacerbée
sur les questions nous rassemblerons
rassemblement à l'aune d'une autre
question qui se pose qui est celle des
municipales je rappelle que tout le
monde a en tête quand même le 15 mars et
que ça fait un peu jurisprudence dans
toutes les têtes donc de réunir des gens
dans des stades ou dans les grandes
compétitions
ça perturbe un peu les équipes
aujourd'hui et d'organiser des
déplacements qui ferait plus de 800
kilomètres quand on dit aux français qui
sont en zone rouge qu'ils peuvent pas en
faire plus de 100 il ya une forme de
cohérence aussi vous vous défendez on
répandait la position des fonds la faune
des présidents certains clubs et
finalement du gouvernement dit est de
dire on arrête tout jusqu'à la saison
prochaine
en tout cas c'est la décision qui a été
prise une organisation des digues qui
étaient prises en ce sens une
résignation des faits des 400 ce sens et
maintenant organisons-nous
financièrement pour que tout cela tienne
un mot sur les joueurs et puis on parle
des supporters dans un instant il ya du
chômage partiel comment ça se passe pour
eux mais ça pose un vrai problème aussi
et saucier sociétal c'est à dire que
lorsque le gouvernement ap paix le
chômage partiel de certains clubs qui
est financé par des fonds de pension
américain ou ailleurs ça pose des vrais
problèmes d'éthique
vous comprenez lorsque lorsque les fonds
de pension à lille investi à lille etc
on fait payer à l'état des salaires de
certains joueurs ça crée des problèmes
après sa crête d'autres problèmes aussi
je pense que les les joueurs du psg
aurait dû accepter une baisse de salaire
comme les joueurs de barcelone ont fait
ou même de report de salaire comme les
joueurs de la juventus
parce que s'annonce un mauvais ils ont
refusé que c'est par rapport aux
supporters c'est pas cool et par rapport
et par rapport aussi au salarié du psg
du club du psg où visiblement il voir
des plans sociaux de terrible dans les
clubs parce que on parle bien sûr des
grands des gros salaires de démarrer les
affaires tout ça mais on parle aussi de
ceux qui sont dans les coulisses les
administratifs et où il tout le monde
aurait pu faire un effort au niveau là
pour montrer l'exemple quoi ce qui n'a
pas été fait c'est une grande réforme du
foot français que vous souhaitez oui
mais là ce que parce qu'on vit on vit
sur un train killed mais depuis des
années moi je pense qu'on n'a pas à
l'armée ça depuis le colis des locaux
vides n'est simplement que les acer
version de ce qui s'est passé quoi alors
me parler un peu des supporters
question parce que je pensais mais le
relâche d'état sont totalement
interrogative que le chômage partiel
avait été limitée à 4,5 smic
donc je sais pas s'il a été étendue au
total est en tout cas les clubs ont pris
ce qu'ils pouvaient prendre mais voilà
donc et ensuite c'est les clubs qui
paient la différence mais le bouchon
pour cent de leur salaire
est ce qu'on peut imaginer des matchs
sans public sache a évolué moi je pense
pas moi pour le coup et c'est d'ailleurs
le communiqué goustiers des quarante
deux associations de supporters qui sont
qui constituent l'association nationale
des supporters la haine est ce qu'ils
avaient dit qu'ils étaient pour cet
arrêt du championnat dès lors qu' il
pouvait pas y avoir de match qui se
déroulait sans publions que la
distanciation sociale dans les stades
vous vous y croyez
c'est possible non je joue au contraire
je dis que dès lors qu'on n'est pas
capable de réunir des gens dans les
stades alors on ne peut pas avoir de
deux matchs parce que à bon qu'est ce
qui se passe qu'est ce qui se passe
aujourd'hui qu'est ce qui se passe tout
d'abord je vais m'attirer huis clos ça
permet on vient le voir à l'écran juste
derrière moi le rassemblement qui va au
paris saint germain
ça vous savez quand ccc la semaine du 12
mars c'était même le 11 mars c'était le
match retour de p&g dortmund là ç'aurait
pu être un cluster est donc logiquement
tous les supporters de football veulent
aller voir leur équipe parce que
qu'est-ce que c'est un match à huis clos
aujourd'hui c'est une sanction
collective qui est pris par la
commission de discipline de la ligue de
football professionnel donc quand on
fait un match en public c'est une
sanction acceptée comme normal tout le
monde tout le monde s'est regardé le
match
schalke 04 contre dortmund il sur bin
sport parce qu'il y avait du football
sincèrement maintenant il faut dire les
choses série c'est moi je suis heureux
pour bing porte qu'ils ont des images
etc ont revu du football c'est pas du
football ce n'est pas du football
pourquoi on dirait un match de pré
saison avec des joueurs à bout de
souffle où il n'y a pas
il n'y a pas de célébration est rien le
football il a avant tu pour avant tout
populaire ce qui expliquait tout à
l'heure tu as mieux lorsqu'il expliquait
ses valeurs morales qu'il a acquise
grâce au football le dernier la mixité
sociale
c'est le seul endroit où toutes les
races toutes les religions se mélangent
si aujourd'hui il n'y a pas de ça ça
sert à rien dans ces cas là boum ça ne
se réduit pas du business et ce business
line n'a aucun sens moi ce que je
reproche là c'est que d'avoir traité le
football business
parce que faut pas se leurrer on n'est
pas non plus d on n'est pas les enfants
oui c'est un business aujourd'hui mais
on peut pas traiter le football comme le
handball en france c'est une industrie
et c'est une industrie qui v qui vit une
catastrophe industrielle comme vie le
tourisme aujourd'hui
bon ben vous voyez là dessus on va dire
un mot quand même de votre rapport parce
que ça qu'il est un peu à contretemps
puisqu'il a été vous avez été missionné
avec marie george buffet bien avant la
crise du coc vide sur les supporters
vous proposez quoi pour comprendre
rapidement clairement bas il est à
contretemps
oui et non parce que pour le coup les
matchs seront lieu à huis clos alors que
je vous dis que c'était des sanctions
parce qu'on parle de libertés publiques
et de police administrative et parce
qu'en fait finalement on propose de
prendre un virage un peu un peu à 180
degrés par rapport à ce qui a été fait
ces 20 dernières années qu'ils avaient
été entre entamé quand même en 2016 avec
la création de l'instance nationale des
supporters du supportérisme qui réunit
les instances la ligue la fédé les
pouvoirs publics les supporters pour
discuter et on propose de revoir
drastiquement le cadre des interdictions
administratives vous voulez globalement
alléger les sanctions qu'ils
actionnaient de rendre le principe d un
déplacement qui sont aujourd'hui trop
souvent interdits de pouvoir légaliser
l'usagé de fumigènes de pouvoir
interdire les sanctions collectives de
pouvoir lutter plus efficacement avec
des fonds d'actions contre les
discriminations et notamment pas avoir
ce qu'on a vu sur l'homophobie le
racisme récemment ou encore sur sociaux
ont été créés les ombres supporters
faire du tout répressif arabes vis-à-vis
du l'attitude du gouvernement sera
uniquement ensemble et sur le tout
répressif par rapport aux supporters et
j'ai l'impression que c'est exactement
la cité du brand
un peu question de discernement on
interdite et ont fait une interdiction
globale et c'est fini pour boucler ce
débat le mot de la fin sacha ollier au
contraire je pense que justement il a la
position des supporters est entendue
puisque c'était bien là celle qu'ils ont
qu'ils ont défendues autres aires le
communiqué qui a été transmis par
l'association et on vous invitera des
clés match reviendront pas ce qu'ils
reviendront avec des supporters avec du
public et on verra justement ce qui se
passe au niveau des fumées 7 vous avez
cinq secondes quelques secondes je te
dire c'est une tartufferie monsieur le
député a raison parce qu'en fait le
supporters et les films chaînes font
partie du spectacle
il suffit de regarder pourquoi la
télévision elle connaît fait l'analyse
on filme en premier c'est toujours les
spectacles de la v rod techniques dont
je fais partie c'est d'ailleurs pour ça
que canal a payé moins cher les droits
parce qu'il est plus personne dans les
tribunes
merci merci et passionnant et vous êtes
passionné et c'est agréable parce que ça
se transmet merci beaucoup merci
stéphane d'avoir participé avec moi à ce
débat on va parler à présent d'un
phénomène qui touche toute l'europe et
particulièrement la france
la crise a fait basculer des millions de
personnes dans la pauvreté depuis le
début du confinement les associations
voient affluer un nouveau public non
plus seulement des sans abri mais des
familles qui ont faim des travailleurs
pauvres encore plus pauvres des
demandeurs d'emploi empêché de retrouver
du travail
avant d'accueillir nos invités pour
parler de tout cela caméra embarquée
dans une épicerie solidaire à nanterre
avec un méta zir et nathalie qui doit
reportage au coeur de nanterre en
banlieue parisienne
bienvenue à l'épicerie locale et
solidaire un espace de 300 m² un magasin
qui permet à 82 familles de la commune
de bénéficier de tarifs exceptionnels
sur les produits de première nécessité
parmi ces familles aujourd'hui mélanie
élève seule ses deux enfants elle a
perdu son travail il y a un an
elle vient à l'épicerie pour trouver des
produits frais des concerts des fruits
et légumes ou encore des surgelés
comme dans n'importe quel supermarché
elle pourra acheter des aliments ou des
produits hygiéniques
sauf qu'à la caisse elle ne payera que
10% de ce qu'elle a mis dans son panier
ancien cadre dans l'informatique chez la
bnp mélanie gagné 2500 euros par mois
aujourd'hui pas évident de demander de
l'aide aux associations caritatives
mais avec le confinement elle n'avait
pas le choix
je pense que je n'aurais pas pu passer
le confinement sincèrement ça a été un
coup dur parce que du coup on se
retrouve avec les enfants donc
effectivement et moi ils vont la conti à
la cantine je paye 20 euros pour six
semaines
et d'un coup je me retrouve à payer 4
pas pour les enfants toute la journée et
je les ai gardés trois semaines non stop
donc au bout d'un moment est ici
l'épidémie agit comme un cercle vicieux
mélanie a bien tenté de retrouver du
travail mais la crise sanitaire
l'empêchent de reprendre un poste
enfin j'ai commencé à redresser les a
fait passer des entretiens et là on me
dit ben oui vous allez pouvoir commencer
début mai et pas des mots mais les
enfants ne vont pas à l'école parce que
ben ils sont pas dans la tranche d'âge
qu'il faut l'école c'est à partir du 25
mai donc voilà l'objet dire non je peux
pas bon parce à quelqu'un d'autre
depuis le début du confinement les ong
voient affluer un nouveau public de
personnes démunies non plus seulement
des sans abri mais les travailleurs
précaires appauvris par le confinement
des personnes fortes baisses de revenus
à cause de confinement alors c'est des
gens qui ont des des boulots au noir ou
des femmes de ménage mais leur employeur
les uns pas déclaré en chômage partiel
ils savent pas quand ils vont retrouver
c'est des gens qui avaient des activités
indépendantes
on a on a eu aussi des consultants et
qui n'ont plus le moindre activité et
commis des marais dans la profession et
sont complètement coincé et viennent à
l'épicerie pour pour survivre le temps
que le reprenne
alertés par la situation le gouvernement
a prévu de verser ce mois ci une aide
d'urgence de 150 euros par famille
bénéficiaire du rsa ou l'allocation de
solidarité spécifique insuffisant répond
françois soulage ridicule pas assez
c'est pas suffisant
trop tardives et insuffisantes et et
ponctuelle on nous aurait dit ben vous
accorde 150 euros par mois là ont
commencé à réfléchir les enfants c'est
intéressant mais 150 euros d'un coup
c'est passé largement pas suffisant au
do sul des gens parce que si on fait pas
attention il ya des gens qui vont crever
de faim je peux vous dire dans cette
ville de nanterre aujourd'hui il ya des
gens qui ne mangent pas à leur faim
des responsables avertissent
on arrive à saturation la demande est
très forte les équilibres budgétaires
risquent de ne plus tenir dans les
semaines à venir à cause de la crise
sanitaire
en attendant mélanie ses deux enfants
s'affairent dans le nouveau potager un
jardin collaboratif qui permettra au
magasin de ne plus dépendre des dons et
de proposer des légumes frais cultivés
sur place venez venez on va regarder
montreux - la salade voilà face à cette
crise sociale qui se profilent comme
étant d'ampleur eh bien ce sont les élus
locaux qui sont en première ligne
bonsoir olivier becht merci d'avoir
accepté notre invitation vous êtes
député udi agir du haut-rhin votre ville
mulhouse évidemment a payé un lourd
tribut 1 depuis le début du coc vide
elle est aujourd'hui particulièrement
touché par cette nouvelle pauvreté vous
allez nous en parler tout comme votre
département la seine saint denis bronze
soir stéphane peut vous êtes député
communiste merci d'être là et puis en
duplex via skype elle nous attend il
mérillon bonsoir et merci d'avoir
accepté cette invitation vous êtes
membre du bureau national des restos du
coeur et je vais commencer par l'acteur
de terrain que vous êtes avant tout on
le voyait dans le reportage la demande
alimentaire bon marché elle n'est plus
cantonné seulement aux familles aux
familles modestes sans travail est-ce
que vous dans les restos du coeur dans
les différents départements du
territoire
vous les voyez ces nouveaux public
afflue et bien sûr et je crois que votre
reportage on a une liste de personnes
notamment les personnes qui ont des
enfants à l'école qui d'habitude mange
pas des tarifs sociaux à la cantine
scolaire qui se retrouvent à les nourrir
tous les jours mais aussi les
indépendants qui avaient commencé une
une activité il ya très peu de temps
qu'ils ne peuvent pas bénéficier du
chômage partiel
les intermittents les travailleurs
saisonniers dont des gens qui n'étaient
pas qui était dans une situation un peu
difficile à lalimite de basculer dans la
précarité et que la crise a fait
basculer dans cette précarité on les
voit aujourd'hui arriver dans nos
centres de distribution voire pour
certains d'entre eux dans nos
distributions de rue + 40 % de hausse de
la demande au secours populaire c'est
énorme là
est-ce que vous mesurez la même demande
et les mêmes augmentations de demande
pour les restos du coeur alors oui c'est
de l'ordre de grandeur si celui-là dans
la rue on chiffre à 40 % la la demande
supplémentaire dans nos centres de
distribution on a beaucoup plus de mal
aujourd'hui à avoir des chiffres précis
mais c'est probablement à l'ordre de
grandeur que vous citez et on a une
référence qui nous inquiète pour
l'avenir c'est celle des suites de la
crise financière de 2008 2009 dans les
trois ans qui avait suivi les personnes
accueillies avait augmenté de 25% aux
restos du coeur et donc c'est cela qui
nous fait peur on se dit aujourd'hui
dans l'urgence on arrive à tenir le coup
mais dans trois mois dans quatre mois
que se passera-t-il est et concerne à la
géographie du pays
est ce que certains territoires sont
épargnés ou c'est l'ensemble du
territoire qui est touché par par cette
crise sociale et par cette demande d'
aide alimentaire ont passé dont on
trouve dans des proportions variables
évidemment dans tous les départements
les mêmes situations mais évidemment ce
sont les quartiers les plus populaires
les zones où il ya le chômage le plus
intense qu'ils sont évidemment les plus
les plus marquées par ce phénomène et de
quoi manquez-vous le plus on sait on va
y revenir qu'il ya eu déjà des aides
d'état pour les associations pour les
ong notamment les restos du coeur
aujourd'hui comment faire pour vous
aider
mais alors les aides que nous avons
reçues et notamment de l'état sont des
aides d'urgence dont quels étaient les
bienvenus on en avait besoin pour passer
cette période très difficile
mais ce qui nous préoccupe beaucoup plus
c'est dans trois mois dans quatre mois
dans cinq mois quand arrivera la crise
sociale de cons qu'on annonce un qui
sera très forte et qui suivra la crise
sanitaire
c'est là où nous aurons besoin très
fortement du soutien de l'état des
collectivités locales qui nous aident à
en permanence et aussi peut-être un
point dont on parle moins mais qui est
très important pour nous c'est l'aide de
l'europe
aujourd'hui un repas sur trois a
distribué aux restos du coeur vient de
l'europe
or l'europe est en train de renégocier
dans des conditions très difficiles
son budget pour les années 2000 21 2027
et les premiers scénarios qui nous
inquiète et nous et nos collègues
d'autres associations comme les banques
alimentaires la croix-rouge ou secours
populaire c'était une division par 2
donc pour nous ça serait absolument
catastrophique et donc on insiste
vraiment beaucoup auprès des
parlementaires européens mais aussi
auprès des gouvernements des états
membres sur la nécessité absolue d'avoir
une dimension sociale dans la politique
européenne aujourd'hui cette dimension
sociale c'est un euro par an et par
européen c'est ridiculement faible il
faut absolument poursuivre et augmenter
cette cette politique sociale de l'union
européenne et le message est passé je
reviens vers vous dans un instant
olivier becht qu'est ce que vous vous
constatez sur le terrain dans votre
ville de mulhouse est ce que ces files
d'attenté qui s'allongent dans les
demandes de distribution alimentaire
elles existent également
mais moi je suis allé visiter le centre
d'approvisionnement des restos du coeur
pour faire justement un peu le point à
la fois sur les stocks et sur les
demandes et j'ai constaté de manière
assez inattendue d'ailleurs parce qu'on
pouvait penser que la crise allait venir
après le déconfinement on voit bien
qu'on a une crise sanitaire qui la
partie émergée être à bergues et bien
que derrière on va avoir la crise
économique et sociale toutes ces
entreprises qui n'arrivent pas à
reprendre celle qui reprennent mais
uniquement avec une partie des salariés
est en réalité la pauvreté elle a
augmenté déjà durant le confinement est
sur le terrain on a on a constaté
effectivement plus 30 % de demandes aux
restos du coeur au moment même où les
stocks des restos du coeur était à 50%
de leurs capacités c'est à dire qu'on
est dans une situation extrêmement
tendue
avant même que cette crise économique et
sociale de montres tous ses effets c'est
à dire avant même que le chômage partiel
ne s'arrête
une date qui est exactement nous sommes
encore en situation de chômage partiel
au moins jusqu'à la fin du mois de juin
et nous avons derrière leur bien sûr
pour le secteur du tourisme ce sera un
peu plus long le gouvernement a donné
des assurances jusqu'au mois de
septembre
mais nous avons beaucoup d'entreprises
qui sont aujourd'hui en situation
d'attenté
elles n'ont pas de perspective on ne
sait pas d'ailleurs si ce virus va
disparaître réapparaître à l'automne
prochain sous forme saisonnière ou
rester de manière permanente dont il ya
un problème d'anticipation pour les
entreprises les entreprises aujourd'hui
ne sont pas optimistes la confiance
n'est pas là et donc nécessairement
quand la confiance n'est pas là
l'emploi n'est pas au rendez vous il ya
beaucoup de chômeurs partiels qui
risquent de devenir des chômeurs tout
court et c'est extrêmement préoccupant
pour la situation sanitaire et sociale
de notre pays
alors on va venir aux mesures et aux
dispositifs qu'est-ce qu'il faut faire
vous allez nous décrire quand même
stéphane peu ce qui se passe en sept
samedi parce que c'est particulier aussi
la seine-saint-denis il ya des appels
aux dons qu'est ce qu'on fait déjà quand
on a un élu de terrain et qu'on voit
cette vague remonter qu'est ce qu'on
peut faire pour aider les gens d'abord
j'aime même pour ce qui me concerne j'ai
participé tous les week-ends des
distributions il ya beaucoup
d'associations de jeunes dans les
quartiers qui se sont mobilisés qui ont
changé leurs activités traditionnelles
pour faire de la de la distribution qui
ont su aussi s'adapter à des publics qui
n'avaient pas l'habitude d'aller
chercher des colis alimentaires et pour
qui l'anonymat le fait que le colis
puisse être déposée devant la porte
qu'ils ne se montrent pas dans une file
d'attenté quelque chose
exemples et des travailleurs
indépendants montrent clairement des
gens des gens chômage qui à celle il ya
aussi des bains où ça il ya eu beaucoup
de drames dans ce talent ça continue il
ya les gens qui avaient les les chômage
partiel et qui avait une perte de revenu
il ya les indépendants qui n'avais plus
de revenu du tout il ya des intérimaires
on en parle assez peu mais beaucoup
d'intérimaires qui ont vu les contrats
d'intérim stoppée le 15 mars et pas
d'inscription à pôle emploi donc zéro
revenu il ya tous les gens qui avaient
des métiers d'appoint vous savez ce
matin j'étais avec le secours populaire
à l'université paris 8 sur des sur une
distribution pour les étudiants chaque
semaine de secours populaire a été
devant l'université paris 8 et continue
pour les étudiants mais vous avez des
étudiants c'est absolument dramatique
des étudiants qui faisait du baby
sitting pour arrondir leurs fins de mois
qui font que le baby sitting qui faisait
des extras dans les restaurants ou dans
dans des commerces qui ne font plus
d'extrait et qui n'ont plus rien alors
il ya eu l'aide de 200 euros mais qui
est une aide pour une
en une seule fois et en plus pour aller
pour les gens de moins de 25 ans et une
université paris 8 il ya beaucoup
d'étudiants salariés qui parfois ont
plus de 25 ans ils n'ont pas touché
l'aide de deux si vous le voulez bien je
voudrais qu'on arrive aux solutions même
si évidemment vos témoignages sont
précieux pour prendre la mesure de ce
qui se passe et de ce qui monte dans le
pays il ya déjà des dispositifs des
daims ou plus modestes qui ont été mises
en place la trêve hivernale a été
prolongée pour empêcher des expulsions
locatives ya eu 7 euros par jour et par
personne pour les sans abri 150 euros
plus 100 euros
s'il ya un enfant à charge pour tous les
bénéficiaires du rsa et de la ss et ses
fameux 200 euros dont vous parliez pour
les étudiants qui ont perdu leur travail
on entendait dans le reportage se ce
monsieur du secours alimentaire qui
disait mais 150 euros c'est pas
suffisant
non c'est pas bon d'abord c'est pas
suffisant parce que c'est en une seule
fois et en fait la situation elle
malheureusement elle est pérenne
ça va faire maintenant bientôt deux mois
qu'on est dans cette situation et ça se
prolonge et la reprise va pas se faire
il ya la question qui était évoqué par
le responsable des restaurants du coeur
et qui m'a été signalé par le secours
populaire de l'aide européenne
aujourd'hui la plupart des associations
caritatives fonctionne soit les stocks
de la communauté européenne et
aujourd'hui ce matin dans les entrepôts
du secours populaire à romainville
y avait il restait que 10 % de 2,2 de
l'aide qui normalement doit aller
jusqu'à la fin 2020 ça veut dire que
dans quinze jours il ya plus rien et
pour l'instant il n'y a pas de réponse
du côté de la communauté européenne pour
savoir s'il fallait débloquer une aide
d'urgence ou pas qu'est ce que vous
faites il ya des questions dette
d'urgence est quoi un appel aux dons
vous dites au gouvernement d'amplifier
d'enfin pense qu'il faut amplifier les
filet social
il ya un immense problème on en parlera
peut-être plus tard mais un immense
problème qui est corrélée à la situation
sociale c'est la question du logement
des loyers ou des charges de copropriété
c'est c'est une bombe à retardement
j'écoutais louis gallois qui préside
l'ancien patron de deux d'air france qui
est président maintenant une association
une fédération d'associations
d'hébergement qui appellent au secours
parce qu'il va y avoir sur la question
du logement
moi j'ai des propositions très concrètes
elle arrive que je pourrais les formuler
tout à l'heure je voudrais aussi qu'on
fasse un petit comparatif avec nos
voisins européens parce que la crise est
violente
elle montre mais parfois elle est plus
violente à à l'étranger chez nos voisins
d'un beau vous qu'est ce que vous
réclamez des pouvoirs publics c'est à la
hauteur où il va falloir monter en
puissance
moi je pense que il faut savoir saisir
la chance de notre malheur on va vivre
une crise extrêmement profonde peut être
la plus dure la plus violente qu'on ait
jamais connues dans l'époque moderne
depuis la crise de 1929
c'est le moment ou jamais de changer
notre modèle économique social et
environnemental
c'est l'occasion c'est maintenant on a
cette possibilité de réformer
profondément les choses
alors on a effectivement une seule une
solution une possibilité c'est de dire
on va distribuer de l'argent comme ça
de retour à l'état providence classique
mais c'est aussi distribuer l'argent
qu'on n'a pas forcément si c'est pour
l'emprunter aux générations futures et
faire payer tout ça à nos enfants à
travers les impôts de demain
ce n'était pas nécessaire alors moi je
pense que nous avons un passage possible
entre une logique qui pour l'instant
était une logique assurantielle le
chômage vous cotisez vous avez droit à
une allocation à une logique qui
pourrait être une sorte de protection
universelle
on pourrait garantir à chaque personne
alors un revenu mais peut-être attachée
à un contrat à durée indéterminée et
dire à quelqu'un mais vous avez des
compétences ses compétences elles
correspondent à un cdi nous vous
garantissons un cdi qui peut être
portable avec un revenu associée
lorsque l'on peut vous mettre dans une
entreprise parce que il ya de l'emploi
qui correspond à vos compétences vous le
prenez mais si vous n'avez pas cette
possibilité
eh bien nous vous garantissons ce revenu
mais en contrepartie nous vous
demanderons de faire une formation qui
permet d'adapter à vos compétences aux
besoins du marché
ou alors éventuellement des missions
d'utilité sociale de l'engagement
associatif c'est à dire une contrepartie
à la solidarité la contribuer
pour le monde d'après inquiet
aujourd'hui est sur la table
bonsoir géraldine woessner et merci
d'être avec nous depuis votre domicile
j'imagine vous êtes chroniqueuse dans
cette émission
ce sont évidemment les contraintes
sanitaires de sécurité 1 qui qui nous
l'imposent malheureusement devrait bien
aimé vous avoir physiquement avec nous
vous êtes journaliste au point je le
rappelle est ce qu'on est mieux loti
dans cette période avec ces aides
sociales ou moins bien que que nos
voisins européens
écoutez c'est vrai ça n'a pas soulagé ce
qu'ils font là qu aujourd'hui dans les
banques alimentaires mais oui la
situation il faut en avoir conscience
est bien pire dans la majorité des
autres des autres pays du monde l'europe
finalement c'est le continent qui s'en
sort le mieux la fédération européenne
des banques alimentaires qui regroupe 29
pays estime que la demande pour de la
nourriture d'urgence à a augmenté ces
deux derniers mois de 20 à 25 pour son
groupe
oui c'est beaucoup mais ça a été
vraiment limité par notre filet social
le chômage partiel qui n'a pas été
partout au même niveau à la france a
vraiment été la plus généreuse en
angleterre par exemple beaucoup de gens
avaient des petits jobs il était que de
70 pour cent le chômage partiel est
plafonnée avec des plafonds très bas
pour les demandes là pour l'aide
alimentaire elles ont explosé + 60 % en
allemagne le chômage partiel habib été
aussi de 2 60% du salaire est dans un
pays où il ya huit millions de petits
jobs la bascule dans la pauvreté s'est
fait très vite et on a vu revenir
exactement comme en france des familles
qui pouvaient pas payer trois repas
parce qu'elle est plus non plus 2 quand
il donc la situation reste difficile
mais maintenant on le sait vous invitez
l'ont très bien dit le pire en europe
il reste à venir avec la crise sociale
mais comment ça se passe dans les pays
qui n'ont pas justement ce chômage
partiel cette indemnisation du chômage
partiel comme les états unis aux états
unis très mal pendant cette crise
imaginez 36 millions d'américains ont
perdu leur emploi se sont retrouvés au
chômage d'un coup en deux mois le taux
de chômage a explosé hibbard frôler les
20% au mois de mai
alors des aides ont été votés 600 $ par
semaine pour tous les chômeurs ça paraît
beaucoup pour nos 600 $ par semaine sauf
cotées aux états unis dans des villes
comme new york ou los angeles a fermé
pas du tout de vivre les loyers sont
délirants il faut payer son assurance
santé ses factures donc là la demande
pour de l'aide alimentaire a vraiment
explosé elle a doublé dans certains
endroits au point où commence à se dire
que le plan massif fin de 2200 milliards
des de voter par donald trump risque de
ne pas suffire
alors même si les états unis ou fin
imaginez un peu le reste du monde
un demi milliard d'indiens qui vivaient
dans les villes qui avaient besoin de
leur salaire journalier pour manger se
sont jetés sur les routes pour rejoindre
la campagne en exode comme on n'en avait
pas vu depuis depuis l'indépendance
ça a été dans énormément de partie du
monde ça a été extrêmement difficile on
pense à l'afrique à l'amérique du sud
les nations unies estiment d'ailleurs
que le nombre de gens qui souffrent de
la faim directement de la fin va doubler
d'ici la fin de l'année à 265 millions
de personnes et ce qui est très triste
myriam c'est que celle là c'est une fin
silencieuse une fin invisible il n'y a
pas de médias dans ces pays avait pas de
médias dans les bidonvilles qui s'en
retrouve est fermé parlant fermée par le
confinement sans nourriture est pour
beaucoup dans ces pays-là la fin va tuer
plus que le coville merci merci
géraldine ça fait froid dans le dos un
ce tour d'horizon n'est pas forcément
moins bien lotis que les autres même si
effectivement le plus dur reste à venir
vous restez avec nous ça va vous
intéresser parce que c'est l'heure de la
chronique de thomas des prêts pour sa
journée à l'assemblée thomas qui s'est
plongée dans les coulisses du monde
politique d'après thomas alors que
mijote le président remaniement
consultation des français
il est où thomas aujourd'hui bon sens
myriam j'étais en train d'étudier les
différentes options institutionnels cas
emmanuel macron pour l'après crise covit
je vais vous raconter tout ça
[Musique]
que va faire emmanuel macron pour
marquer l'après crise du coronavirus et
amorcer un changement de politique c'est
myriam le sujet qui agite pas mal de
député et un certain nombre
d'intellectuels parce que maillol macron
il a dit ça il nous faudra demain tirer
les leçons du moment que nous traversons
alors que faire pour amorcer un éventuel
changement de cap du présidentmd
plusieurs options seraient à l'étude un
remaniement un gouvernement d'union
nationale un référendum ou encore une
dissolution de l'assemblée nationale
comme le propose un ancien conseiller du
président de la république alors qu'en
pensent les députés des différents
partis avec rabbi cas cet après midi on
est allé à leur rencontre
qu'est ce qu'il faut faire pour marquer
le début du monde d'après je suis pas
sûr que ça se passe avec emmanuel macron
le monde d'après je crains même l'un
vers ce qu'il faudrait c'est changer de
majorité ouvrir une alternative de
gauche c'est de ça dont nous avons
besoin ce qui est certain c'est que bien
que le président de la république
viennent de perdre sa majorité absolue
un requin retour aux urnes aujourd'hui
le mettrait inévitablement dans une
situation de cohabitation s'imagine mal
congrès à versailles j'ai lu ça quelque
part
au moment où on peut pas se rassembler
dans les salles allait mettre neuf cents
députés sénateurs qui n'a pas de sens ce
référendum et ou dissolution ses larmes
du président et enfin on dit toujours
que c'est leur multeam qui on veut
renverser la table maintenant si on veut
proposer ce projet maintenant le
meilleur moyen me semble-t-il c'est une
élection présidentielle avec une
élection législative juste derrière qui
re donne cinq ans pour mettre en oeuvre
ce projet qui aura été validé à ce
moment là par l'ensemble des citoyens
français
du côté de la majorité difficile de
savoir laquelle de ces options tient la
corde
de toute façon à la fin c'est le
président qui aura le dernier mot
mais on a tout de même voulu avoir leur
regard sur ces différentes propositions
est ce que vous pensez qu'il faut
dissoudre l'assemblée nationale
il ya déjà quatre élections qui viennent
dans les huit mois qui viennent les
municipales deuxième tour les
départementales et régionales et les
sénatoriales
je suis pas sûr qu'aujourd'hui qu'on ait
besoin d'une cinquième campagne
électorale on a surtout besoin de passer
en mode efficacité pour se projeter dans
la presse identifié un certain nombre de
pistes et les mettre en oeuvre
je ne suis pas sûr que ce soit la piste
que je privilégierai mais comme vous le
savez c'est pas moi qui décide et flins
gouvernement d'union nationale ferait la
bonne option
on a déjà quelques parts aujourd'hui un
gouvernent
d'union nationale on a des gens divers
d'opinion et divers horizons qui se sont
regroupés suite à l'élection du
président macron ça vous aura pas
échappé qu'entre muriel pénicaud et
edouard philippe c'est pas tout à fait
la même famille politique à l'origine et
ces gens là ont pu travailler ensemble
alors pour le moment on ne connaît pas
bien sur le calendrier des scénarios
possibles mais si le président veut
changer d'orientation politique le temps
presse l'élection présidentielle c'est
dans moins de deux ans mais on aura
l'occasion d'en reparler dans ma journée
à l'assemblée
ainsi vous aviez un mot pour ce monde
politique d'après référendum dissolution
remaniement ministériel union nationale
c'est le moment de renverser la table
il faut un nouveau modèle économique
social environnemental le président de
la république emmanuel peuls mais
emmanuel macron peut le porter mais il
va falloir une egypte démocratique est
ce que c'est une élection présidentielle
et législatives est ce que c'est un
référendum
en tout cas il faut que ce soit validé
par les ions c'est pas un mot merci en
tout cas un mot non moi je ne crois pas
du tout alors la capacité d' emmanuel
macron de ceux de s'amender ou de se
réformer son logiciel libéral et est un
socle fondamental chez lui et donc je
pense qu'ils qui va falloir aller des
contre-pouvoirs fois relations sociales
voilà c'est dit allez vous souvenez sans
doute de ses dialogues surréalistes au
comptoir et bien figurez-vous que rien
n'arrête camille saféris même pas le
qu'ovide bonsoir camille quel plaisir de
se retrouver
quel joli bibliothèque que je vois que
je découvre chacun sa bibliothèque 1
dans ces petits skype alors il y en a
des faux seins qui circulent ici et là
mais la mienne est une brute je vous
crois sur parole ce soir vous aviez on
s'en souvient dialoguer longuement avec
des députés je le disais au café accoudé
au comptoir et vous avez décidé de
poursuivre ce dialogue à travers des
apéros des apéros visio c'est ça voilà
des apéros en visio absolument et ce
soir je vais vous parler de sabine rubin
alors sabine rubens et une députée elle
est fille de seine saint denis
c'est une ex enseignante en lettres
elle habite dans le 9 3 évidemment et
c'est un personnage vous allez voir elle
est vraiment très très amusante très
très très sympa évidemment je vais
d'abord demander comment s'était passée
basson déconfinement son retour à la vie
on a parlé de ce qu'elle avait fait
durant la période de confinement normand
au début j'étais contente que tout
s'arrête un franchement ça m'a fait je
me suis reposée enfin en même temps
j'étais sidéré alors quand on est sidéré
on a envie de se poser mais j'étais
content je me suis en fait au début je
me suis dit tiens je vais royan les
bouquins je n'ai pas lu je pouvais
penser écrire moi que jamais le temps en
vérité j'étais sidéré fatigue et puis il
fallait que quand même très rapidement
en fait au bout de deux semaines quand
même que je puis synthétiser tout ce que
j'avais lu compris et c est pouvoir le
pouvoir dire quelque chose au monde
ce convialité quand on est quand même
député ou dans une fonction quelconque
l'a pas toujours prendre quelque chose à
dire rien de plus intelligent que les
autres
oui voilà quand on est député il faut
dire quelque chose de plus intelligent
que les autres c'est souvent ça le
problème
donc alors même en 55 jours sa mine
rubin est là lui elle a mangé
elle a fait des réunions sur zoom et
puis quoi d'autres vous n'avez pas fait
de comme tout le monde dit aux gars là
j'ai pédalé ben oui j'ai fait d'aller
sur mon vélo d'appartement qu'on va et
filet est ce que le fait d'être coupée
des autres c'est à dire d'être un
individu seul isolé puisque on était
chacun chez soi
est-ce que ça oblige à repenser en
termes de politique
la façon dont le pays est gouverné je
pesne seul sur mon vélo d'appartement je
pressens jamais seul je me soucie du
monde donc je fais de la politique
quoi qu'il en soit sur mon vélo
d'appartement je réfléchis à ce monde
pourquoi on en est là qu est ce qui fait
que malgré les alertes alerte alerte
alerte alerte
que ce soit pour les épidémies ou pour
le changement climatique
on ne change pas je suis dans les
réflexions de tous les autres de tous
ceux qui pensent le monde et qui
s'étonnent de le voir arriver à ce stade
là moi ça fait quand même
30-40 ans même que je me pose cette
question là alors en fait
sabine rus bat elle a été élue députée
suite à une blague au moment où il
fallait physique et un candidat c'est
vrai un ce que je vous raconte
c'était le 30 novembre 2016 précisément
un de ses amis a pris son téléphone et a
envoyé un sms à ses camarades pour dire
qu'elle était d'accord alors qu il n
était pas au courant et elle s'est
retrouvée tête de liste est ensuite élu
incroyable mais vrai vous vous ne
vouliez pas être député au départ je
peux toujours pas des relances mana
j'assume mais vous n'aviez pas envie
d'être député et si vous pouviez vous ne
seriez pas je regrette pas à
l'expérience en termes d'apprentissage
personnel de construction d'une pensée
vive prendre la parole c'est difficile
oui du coup c'est un peu comme j'ai un
oral de l'appétit voilà j'acquiers des
compétences comme si je voulais devenir
danseuse mais la fonction en tant que
telle non c'est ridicule à l'heure
actuelle et puis je pense que des gens
tant qu'à faire de la politique si c'est
simplement être un bon orateur maps on
donne aux gens qui ont des compétences
dans ce domaine là
si la politique c'est faire des belles
phrases la rhétorique orange prennent
des cours avant je me représenterai
peut-être après je pense qu'on peut
faire la politique vous voyez du
quotidien la politique du quotidien moi
je vous dis c'est tous les jours
voilà bah c'est incroyable vous arrivez
camille à chaque fois fait ressortir des
choses de nos députés
c'est incroyable ya toujours des perles
j'espère que vous vous prêterez au jeu
de camille saféris avec plaisir
attention c'est risqué merci merci
messieurs on termine comme promis avec
le jour d'après épisode un peu
particulier ce soir à la veille de ce
grand week-end de l'ascension la
réalisatrice au v10 va nous expliquer en
quoi finalement cette période si étrange
a pu modifier notre rapport au corps
notre rapport au sexe également le jour
d'après c'est tout de suite
[Musique]
bell et miles est bien cadré c'est
parfait main super c'est parfait alors
j'ai pas de kit le lie à part un pet de
lumière nature et j'y suis bien
[Musique]
bonjour au vide jour et merci d'avoir
accepté cet entretien on va parler de
sexe avec vous depuis plusieurs semaines
déjà on peut lire toute une série de
reportages de témoignages de français
dont la vie de couple a un peu changé
alors il ya certains qui nous parle
d'une forme d'exutoire face au virus le
sexe ou au contraire d'autres qui nous
disent que leur libido est totalement
chute et d'autres qui vont explorer des
fantasmes face à l'ennui dans le
confinement est ce que cette période là
elle elle vous intéresse en ce que elle
bouleverse
ou pas d'ailleurs notre notre rapport au
sexe gspc être bouleverse notre rapport
au cycle en tout cas elle est
intéressante à observer
parce que déjà elle évolue là on voit
bien là où on en est en ce moment où au
stade de du confinement on voit qu'il ya
une évolution depuis le début c'est à
dire dès les premiers jours il ya eu une
focalisation autour de la sexualité en
général en termes de consommation de
vidéos pornographiques en termes de
questionnements autour du cou qui a lu
énormément de questions dès le début
autour d'eux comment est ce que je vais
faire pour préserver mon couple est ce
qu'on va se séparer on doit y avoir un
baby boom va y avoir des divorces
vraiment on parlait beaucoup de ça on il
y avait aussi beaucoup de blagues sur
les réseaux sociaux je trouve autour
d'eux comment enfin là comment on va
gérer la frustration et j'ai
l'impression que ça se tasse
c'est-à-dire il ya eu il ya eu ce je
pense peut-être cette que sais-je pape
sy met donc je vais faire de l'abc de
comptoir mais cette confrontation à
l'idée de la mort qui à mon avis dans un
premier temps fait qu'on s'est focalisée
autour des questions de sexualité
notre première notre première question
s'était pas est-ce qu'on est au chômage
est ce que est ce qu'on va perdre notre
travail est ce que ça va être est-ce
qu'on va perdre nos proches ça va être
comme angers faire pour baiser voilà et
l'âge on constate quand même
un tassement autour de ces questions là
déjà parce que pour un certain nombre de
couples le confinement a fait ressortir
je dirais pas des difficultés mais je
dirais carrément des des situations
vraiment très problématique voire
toxiques puisque là on se retrouve
confiné on est tout le temps ensemble on
parle beaucoup des disputes qui éclate
mais on a parlé quand même pas mal des
violences conjugales
mais on parle finalement assez peu des
violences sexuelles c'est à dire on
parle des violences au sein du couple
mais le terme violences sexuelles de
termes viol a été rappelé des tricots
prononcer je trouve alors que pourtant
c'est sans que c'est la suite logique de
ces violences là c'est à dire
concrètement à l'heure actuelle on a
certains couples qui sont enfermés
ensemble avec l'impossibilité de
s'extraire du lieu de vie d'habitude il
ya le travail il ya des activités qui
permettent de mettre une certaine
distance je dire au sein du couple là il
ya des femmes qui se retrouvent conques
signer avec parfois un homme qui peut
avoir des besoins je n'aime pas ce terme
mais je dirais des exigences en tout cas
sexuelle et se mélange à ça en plus le
besoin de briser la routine qui encore
une autre injonction qui vient s'ajouter
à savait donc il ya cette idée que voilà
il va falloir essayer de nouvelles
choses
il ya aussi des couples qui se sont
rencontrés dans le confinement c'est que
les sites de rencontres ont explosé
pendant la période ça donne forcément
lieu à une sexualité à distance une
sexualité médiatisé numérique fait
d'écran faite d'image faite de mots
aussi c'est réjouissant ça ou c'est
plutôt triste ni l'un ni l'autre en fait
c'était déjà là finalement quand on y
réfléchit le confinement il exacerbe un
certain nombre de choses qui étaient
déjà bien installée c'est à dire dont
les sites de rencontres ou des
applications n'a pas attendu le
confinement pour faire fonctionner
tender quoi concrètement sait déjà c'est
notre mode de rencontre actuelle donc je
je suis pas sûr que le confinement
change grand-chose grand-chose à ça
après ce qui est intéressant de voir
c'est comment certains couples qui était
déjà le dysfonctionnelle
vont vraiment mettre un terme à la
relation avec les dix ans parce qu'il y
avait des certain qu'on n'était enfin un
certain nombre je dirais à avoir été
dans une relation où l'habitude faisait
on se séparait pas tout à fait et
parfois la mise à distance du au
confinement fait que ben a passé un mois
un mois et demi deux mois on se rend
compte finalement qu'on n'a pas besoin
de l'autre et convient très bien par soi
même il ya peut-être des gens qui vont
se dire j'ai pas besoin de lui où j'ai
pas besoin d'elle et finalement je je
m'aime et je vis très bien par moi même
alors il ya eu une annonce qui a été
faite celle-là c'était au tout début du
confinement et est là elle a fait
beaucoup réagir sur les réseaux sociaux
c'est la gratuité des plateformes de
vidéos pornographiques
qu'est ce que vous en avez pensé alors
en réalité le porno est déjà gratuit sur
toutes ses plateformes là l'écrasante
majorité du porno aujourd'hui est
consommée sur des plateformes gratuites
je crois que c'est 95% de la
consommation mondiale du porno qui passe
par ces plateformes gratuites
donc en fait cette annonce de la
gratuité c'était juste un coup de com
parce qu'en réalité tout était déjà mis
à disposition
mais dans les premiers jours de
confinement et n'a vraiment eu une
hausse colossale du de la consommation
de vidéos de vidéos pornographiques sur
cette page et regarder les chiffres
c'est vrai que c'est énorme un + 38 %
pur porc de robes pour dorcel 32% de
plus c'est énorme
est-ce que vous pouvez nous expliquer
même si effectivement ça s'est un peu
tassé par la suite
ce boom des plateformes porno qui est
allée ce que ça vient combler est ce que
des gens ont découvert le porno alors je
crois pas que des gens aient découvert
le porno parce qu'en fait le porno
concrètement on sait maintenant
statistiquement tout le monde en
consomment dans tous les pays y compris
où c'est interdit
donc cette consommation il était déjà
très présentes on était déjà à peu près
à 300 350 milliards de connexions par an
sur et vidéo pendant qu'on était déjà
voilà tout le monde en consommaient déjà
non
on sait voilà une augmentation de cette
consommation est dans les premiers jours
déjà peut-être pour dissiper une forme
d' angoisse la masturbation ça dissipe
une forme d' angoisses mais aussi parce
que encore une fois il ya eu cette
focalisation autour de la question
sexuelle au début dans ce moment de
confrontation à la mort quoi finalement
c'est je pense je pense que ça a été
juste une réflexion et réaction un peu
un peu humaine mais ce qui est
intéressant de constater quand même
c'est que malgré cette augmentation des
de la consommation de porno l'industrie
du porno elle même n'a pas gagné plus
d'argent c'est à dire il ya eu un
certain nombre de travailleuses du sexe
donc des actrices des call girls qui ont
tiré la sonnette d'alarmé sur les
réseaux sociaux en disant nous n'avons
plus de sources de revenus donc c'est
les travailleuses du sexe qui elles sont
dites chaînes poissons sont les
prolétaires de ce milieu on va dire elle
ne touche pas de reversions là dessus
donc elles sont de fait en souffrance
durant cette période de confinement vous
pensez que la représentation et
uniformiser de la sexualité via ces
sites là au fond vient uniformiser aussi
nos fantasmes ou pas il me semble qu'il
ya eu de fait une uniformisation de nos
fantasmes qui s'est installée ces
dernières années et qui est lié à la
démocratisation se dirait du porno de
l'hyperaccessibilité aux vidéos sur les
plateformes gratuites mais pas que les
codes qui sont en apparence d'autant la
pornographie en réalité sont repris
partout dans l'ensemble de notre culture
et côte du porno il se retrouve dans la
télé réalité ils se retrouvent dans la
publicité
retrouve chez les kardashian enfin je
veux dire kanye west quand même il était
là aujourd'hui il chante et langil mais
il ya encore un an et demi il était
quand même directeur artistique des
pornos bowers faut pas l'oublier ça donc
on est quand même cette corne culture
elle existe bien au delà des frontières
du porno donc de fait sa une influence
sur nous ce qu'on voit dans les séries
dans les pubs ça une influence sur nous
donc évidemment que c'est qu'au delà ils
ont fini par rentrer dans notre intimité
alors justement sur les rapports hommes
femmes
quand ces verrous du confinement vont
sauter quand vous voyez les choses
est-ce qu'on va se jeter les uns sur les
autres dans une une forme voilà de dorgy
de sexe est ce qu'on aura envie de se
toucher de s'étreindre ou au contraire
vous parliez de normes du porno tout à
l'heure il ya une forme de normes qui
est en train d'être intériorisé dans ce
confinement la distanciation sociale une
espèce de peur de l'autre et donc on
prendra son temps avant de faire de
grandes retrouvailles je sais pas déjà
je connais je sais pas ce qu'il va se
passer mais je suis pas certaine qu'on
se rejettent les uns sur les autres ou
alors peut-être le premier jour de
deuxième jour mais pas pas à long terme
ça peut-être j'aimais une hypothèse
peut-être que le confinement pour
certains et certaines d'entre nous nous
ont amenés déjà à repenser notre
existence
en ce moment c'est vrai qu'on parle
beaucoup du monde d'après du monde
d'avant marque quand même une scission
une cassure
on se pose la question de comment va
consommer à l'avenir peut-être que ça va
nous amener aussi à nous poser la
question de comment il a consommé entre
guillemets le sexe à l'avenir aussi
peut-être qu'il ya des gens qui vont se
dire oui peut-être que finalement je
ferais mieux de consommer pendant ma
fille un peu plus éthique ou ce genre de
choses on sépare qu'est ce que vous
voulez dire par pornographie ticket ce
qui serait souhaitable dans le jaï ray
pornographie qui passe pas par des sites
j'irai qui frisent avec l'illégalité qui
ne respectent pas le droit à l'image
qu'ils ne mettent pas en ligne des
vidéos qui ratait qu'il ne mette pas en
ligne des vidéos de revenge porn des
sites sur lesquels on trouve pas de
vidéos avec des mineurs ce qui est quand
même le cas on sait maintenant que
certaines plateformes pornographiques
qui ont pignon sur rue qu'ils font des
grands communiqué de presse
régulièrement équivalent certains
chiffres et on sait bien que certaines
vidéos de revenge porn avec des
adolescentes traîne là dessus merci
beaucoup merci à reading d'avoir répondu
à nos questions et à bien à bientôt
mais ainsi s'achève cette émission ça
vous regarde fait une pause pour ce
grand week end de l'ascension toute
l'équipe vous le souhaite le meilleur
possible ce grand week-end profiter à
mardi
[Musique]